aber nur ein haus wo ich da ein blog
rechen stelle und ist leider ist die man
da sieht man wo seid ihr
hallo wird jetzt bekam zu einem weit
enteilt minecraft heimischen liga und
dann wieder in einer geilen
konstellation unterwegs und zwar ist der
crafter wieder da lang nie mehr gesehen
simon ist drauf voneinander trainer hat
gesagt das ist frieden den hat gesagt
dass es frieden in absatzes wien
denn er sagte es ist frieden ja prima
ich schreibe nie angst alter ich höre
nicht auf denen ich bin schon raus aus
der stadt
ich bin der untergrund egal sie man aber
haben wir frieden das ding ist es ja
gerade auch bei umfragen am laufen ja ob
mann ob man ab jetzt frieden ist und es
sind auch ob er
ob man sich ins haus teleportieren darf
wir wollen nur schön unsere stadt
verschönern diakonie ja doof wenn du und
dabei stürzt das wasser kommt ein extra
jetzt kommt der extra danke simon aber
man da vielleicht richtig angewendet zu
uns kommen würde
unglaublich er verschreibt für die kacke
wir uns hier ist jetzt wirklich
hundertprozentig so eine pussy kacke in
den pvp projekt aber ich sage dazu
nichts vor ein erster verhindern was für
jacke oder rpg richtig rum storniert
zudem stock einer wunde
ist das hier ja role play nicht pvp play
diskussions folgen soll unsere stadt
musikshows mit shader beim start ist ein
kleiner ab ich weiß nicht freund ich
weiß nicht ob ich komme ja bei apg
beinhaltet auf pvp oder ich weiß nicht
ob die schrittfolge ich weiß nicht ob
ich den schädel reinpacken soll oder
nicht
die ffb stören sie man so und seine
aufnahme was ist dieser untergrund ist
er deutscher was ist dieser untergrund
ist er deutscher
wir wollen den diktator gegner stützen
also sucht ihr verbündete wie auch lars
zusammen
zusammen ich habe was mohammed station
voll vier weg ich habe hier so eine
kleine idee gehabt und zwar hab ich mir
gedacht dass ich hier im falle sich
jetzt wundert matra finden scheiße dass
ich diesen stein hier nehme und aus
diesem stein hier so diese mauerbau das
heißt wenn ich dir so baut
beispielsweise ist so dann würden die ja
nicht sehen dass hier eine dimension per
bahn bauen sie sich durch dann macht das
licht aus
ich würde es mal rat mit den dimensionen
weil vielleicht werden dimension ja auch
komplexen ja es stimmt dass hamburg auf
das rad in den diskussionen ob für
dimensionen nicht geschützte wie
privater besitzt da denken wir dass doch
behindert das ist mein grundstück hier
und wenn das wirklich der fall sein
sollte meine mir ist das scheißegal ob
ich meine portaltüren wollt ihr euch die
munteren anschließend nicht anschließen
vertrag oder wir müssen unsere königin
gibt es nun an der ground stripclub
daseins was interessiert wenn es ein
stripclub gibt da bin ich dabei ich will
dass unsere königin das entscheidet
kleine hinterhältigen übrigens danke
leute dass sie mir geschrieben hat dass
ich die frisur tags verzaubern darf das
weiß ich selber aber es hat einfach
vergessen dass zu machen ja gründe ihres
dann mama also die puffmutter ich mich
nicht an das will ich geil alter
steinbruch kathrin puff und unser volk
volkslied für seinen putt putt auf die
eisenbahn wer erfährt mit beschließt und
du redest von papa von mein revier ab
und das ist doof ich habe auch nicht ab
das ist doch geradezu schließlich dem
untergrund an nein ich habe gesagt ich
bleib in der stadt und bei den putts
einfach nur ein haus wo ich da einen
blog gleichen stelle und das leider ist
die man dass sie monatlich an die man
greift nicht an
ja ja ja sie man kann ich mich an wie
simon greift mich an erwarte ich zum
beispiel an der pocket menschen nicht zu
kurz mein zeug in die kisten und komm
raus das kann nicht sein
aber wir das ding ist wir besprechen ja
auch gerade die regeln ob man gold apple
nutzen darf ist oder nicht ist alles
irgendwie gar zu schwammig ich finde es
auch ein bisschen kacke wer nämlich
jetzt töten würde
du schießt micha den abpfiff nur laut
oder nicht das will ich jetzt wissen
wenn apple nämlich nicht erlaubt sind
ich wollte auch noch ein ich schieße
baku hätte so man darf sich aber in der
eigenen welt teleportieren
das heißt wird ja nur gesagt in fremden
städten darf man sie mit dem oxford
teleportieren
das heißt aber nicht dass man das ziel
ich darf und natürlich muss ich meine
us-flugzeug maßstab weg gelegt so etwa
ist gleich darum attacke zu einseitig in
der stadt wo seid ihr
ich konnte dann ein erstes sollte ich
mir total
ich bin gerade durch bin total fertig
sind bei mir auf einem grundstück was
ist hier los
hoffmann hat meldet sich zum dienst was
nur hof mama kev meldet sich zum dienst
nein ich meine das weinhaus hübsch ist
weiß gar nicht wie ich meine
bild fotos zeigen was sache ist
ach so weiß gar nicht was jetzt erwartet
der wartet der wartet bis wenigen krieg
anfangen
du wirst maß geregelt dass ja wir sind
auf der seite der untergrund kritik
greift man sich an
ja ich will auch die diktator stürzen
hashtag nieder mit denen wir wollen
nicht beten wir wollen freiheit nix aber
was haben die anderen da mit zu tun ist
das nicht
ich habe nie elsass mit kriegen zu tun
gehabt doch gott aber ich bin nicht das
ist doch wirklich ich meine das ist doch
ne gefühl kann das gar nicht verstehen
nicht so rot blau manche leute sind
farbenblind hettich abgeschossen kämpft
was du dass sie werden sich geht in
statistik jetzt in meinem spiegel den
stadtrat in den untergrund hat ja mit
untergrund wo bekomme ich gibt weiß
nicht ob es wirklich das ist was los ist
verstehe ich aber nicht also es gibt
wirklich jetzt einen untergrund der sich
da bildet oder wie das verstehe ich
nicht du bist richtig über steuert also
bei mir zumindest übelster über steuer
ich bin jetzt bei 20 prozent
über steuer ist du hast du keine auf
knapp übers tor ist meine aufnahme
provisorisch gehe ich jetzt mal
immenstadt rot grün statt rot
ein auto wurde von euch einen tipp
gegeben
ich bin da ja aber ich hab den spiegeln
bisschen weiter weg gesetzt ich bin bei
dir jetzt hier im wasser
wie war es doch gerade fast da war ich
gerade bin halt in stadtroda ich auch
warum der baum von der balance
abgegangen sagt simon
so jetzt sehen was unter wasser a hatte
führt mit sieben gab es im untergrund
alter das ist ja geil
ja das ist von roth pilz das haus glaube
ich ja denn so richtig schön richtig
schön
ich sehe nichts mehr irgendwo hier muss
das sein aber wo wo seid ihr denn
aja dunkel es kann nicht sein dass du
super start bei mir steuer 0 bei mir zu
heftig ich hab's noch mal ich war steuer
also auf keinen fall also wirklich nicht
wo seit der wählt sich mich ich sehe
wirklich nicht wo ist er denn schütze
diktatur woggon mode waren holzschwert
verstehe ich gar nichts mehr
red devils ist neumann schwert tree
paradies juni der und das ist gar nicht
mal verzaubert irgendwie alle verzaubert
mit from habe ich jetzt hier ein
gepostet hast du das ist der untergrund
das ist der ganze und rund 190 x 3 x 3
dass man das mal angreifen
bayer musste kommen jetzt ja wo denn
ja wir sind im untergrund ja wie komme
ich da rein erwartet kurz cognac mit sag
mir wie du holst cognac okay für stück
so siehst du mich jetzt ich bin hinter
dem stifter auf der wüste krieg war
bisschen rum also nicht meiner stadt
soll ein bisschen weiter weg sein portal
wussten deinen restlichen gebäudes
kommen einfach zu denen das haus nicht
so dass da ist viel zu weit weg
er starb nicht verschwenden wenn du auf
der minimap kopf gibt es rechts von
stieß shift oder eine aufnahme von berg
hat nicht mal angreifen
ja ich bin bei steger schiff nein weil
sich abholen muss habe ich nicht
angegriffen die erzähl ich nichts mehr
jetzt ist es endlich geschafft ich bin
voll war zaubern erste nichts ich habe
doppelt so viele leben wie er ja ich bin
erschöpft
ja ich sag mal bist du dumm boxt
ach so weil du mir das derzeit heftig
weiter also die erste koordinate ist
5400 da siehst du mich müsste ich sehe
nicht aufgehört am strand baywatch
ein am strand 5405 1480 habe ich auch
schon gesehen
die zweite 3900 das ist doch voll nahe
an der stadt alter kommen so scheiße du
bist an mir vorbeigeflogen war
weggeflogen
da ich dachte auf der anderen seite ist
so voll da geht es geht schnell in
untergrund meinst du was auch geil wert
wenn wir jetzt hier im untergrund
bisschen was bauen man machen wo man
untergrund taverne bauen
aus dem untergrund machen liebe grüße
kev und conny oder so ach so kam er zu
mir das ist das ist der untergrund
das ist der gottverdammte untergrund so
wir dürfen aber auch nicht zufrieden ist
ein loch das ist jetzt eigentlich sogar
mit 3 x 3 x 3 kasten das war es simon
dass es peinlich
das prägt mein portal also mache ich mir
nicht so rohn ist ein paar werkzeuge ich
weiß es könnte eventuell irgendwie
verboten seien dort zu bauen ich weiß es
aber nicht ich werde außerhalb von der
stadt ist ja keine offizielle stadt den
raum statt pink ist es denke ich mal
irgendwo okay ich werde jetzt einfach
eine kleine walbaum und das ding ist
unser portal ist ja hier eigentlich auch
direkt also und was mir von euch
angeboten wurde es sind hier
irgendwelche ich weiß gar nicht wie
heißen die schau mal ganz kurz nach und
zwar nennt sich das ganze gast ghost
block b nach kos block dann gibt es ein
graus block der durch den kann man
durchlaufen
er ist aber der passt sich seine
umgebung an das heißt derweil um solche
portaltüren zu blocken
aber wir brauchen so eine camouflage
passte summe all haben
das passte dafür brauchen wir einfach
alle farben das heißt brauchen rot gelb
blau
irgendwie so ich weiß gar nicht in echt
der nummer die farbe von ihm sehen
müssen farben sammeln und erst wenn wir
dann das haben dann geht's ab der grund
bekommt von mir hellem blau als farbe
bin da passe ich hab gar nichts
mitgenommen ich dachte dass wir simon
angreifen plötzlich doch hier abstimmen
sollte ich werde jetzt mal für ein paar
folgen den shader raus packen und es ist
sehr schlampig erstand ins bett legen
vorläufig einmal einsatzes reden ich
werde erstmal den shader kurz raus
packen für die nächsten folgen und dann
die videos allerdings gefährdet ist ins
mal auf plus 64 oder farblos 120 stellen
oder irgend sowas und dann dürft ihr
selbst entscheiden was er findet weil
wir jetzt noch so ein filter drüber
packe dann sieht das so auch ganz cool
aus und für kenntnis ohne für kämpfe
zone steht auch besser und deswegen
jetzt kannst du wieder ins bett schlaft
jetzt einfach mal bei disney das nächste
wird er legt sich einfach hin und ich ja
ich kenne jetzt aber eben bei dehner
glaub ich logge mich einfach aus oder
kümmert hier licht weil ich habe keine
fackeln jetzt soweit ich selbst bei den
nets und schild ich glaube ich schreib
ihm doch als diktator durch bei der
stellt regeln auf das man beten muss für
ihn alles mögliche richtig geilen da
bist du runter vom server ja genau
deswegen okay du hast kannst du drauf
hast immer noch kränklich schade weg
dass das weiß jetzt nicht das ding ist
ich hab das gefühl seit dem ersten krieg
ich kann den leuten nicht mehr vertrauen
und ist immer noch verpackt dunkel hier
das heißt sie muss aber eine fackel
holen erst noch es besser
weil dann werden sich die freuen ich war
das heißt nicht dass wir im untergrund
pro sind dass ich bin sage ich mal ein
lebenskünstler und ein lebenskünstler
der sorgt dafür dass lud er zu egal
welcher situation irgendwie überlebt und
genau das werde ich tun
das heißt ich werde überleben wenn es
hart auf hart kommt und wenn ja was
situation entscheiden wird geschrieben
wer hätte da so ein schild stehen
langlebigen junge den abschluss macht
lange sterbe ging an den in der stadt
vor seinem haus es ist ja nicht sein
haus wie fing ich habe es gleich
dahingestellt er kann's einfach geändert
das haben brachten fans auch schon
gelder die haben ja immerhin geschrieben
berichtet berichtet ach ja auch schon so
eine art eine schoko fahren wir markt
hat geschickt chocobos für alle wild
gegen jena wurde kam es dann zum
computer sondern alle sind gegen ihn
einfach nicht so ein auf adolf hitler zu
machen zuerst sind ganzen leute so wenn
dann auch ein pr gag sein
na ja kein pr gag hoffen dass hier
ansichtssache dabei wird der heutige tag
ich will dieses thema gar nicht
anschneiden weg noch irgendwelche ich
glaube wir können ja wir können ja über
thomas hitzlsperger die oberschule
allgemeine obwohl die folgen einer
minute vorbei von ich habe hunger
das warme hat nämlich auch schon conny
gefragt weiß spielt ja auch
leidenschaftlich fußball
ob er jetzt auch schwul ist das hat
verneint
ja klar wenn der schule es dann aber
jetzt auf meine haut hängen musst du
auch es gibt keine andere wahl
du musst nein was ich habe mein statt
blau spiel gerade verkackt alter
aber hier ist doch ein blog über mir war
scheiße wo muss ich ihn verwenden
so also ich denke ich hier mache ich das
denn
aber anders irgendwie wie bist du denn
zurückgekommen ich habe beim portal das
wollte ich dir zeigen oder dass du so
getötet da hatte ich kein bock mehr
jetzt geht es glaube ich hoffe ich nein
bitte nicht bitte nicht bitte nicht
bitte nicht und ich bin wieder in
stadtroda gelehrig braucht ein portal
oder hast du irgendwas zu essen weil ich
habe nichts zu essen also nichts dabei
leider nicht weil ich jetzt gerade bock
ich bin sondern ich hab wirklich nicht
aber ich liebe dieses wort bockig das
beschreibt so perfekt dieses kleine
kinder verhalten
ich feiere das käfig kannst du
vielleicht damit ein portal eben zeigen
ja kaum steine harten untergrund ich bin
nämlich qatar und baue wo ich habe kein
ich sterbe ich sterbe vor
aber schreibt ihr und dem surfen ja
deswegen ich glaube etwas bei denen das
ist junge das ist die idee nicht gibt es
diese folge noch zurück obwohl sind laut
dann leute gar nicht kommen ich sterbe
vor hunger kämpfer chips zu mir ich
wollte gar zum portal fliegen mich über
porten und dir was geben wenn dir so
klaus und klaus du ich finde ja nicht
mal wasser doch da eine woche eine
maschine auf hat was war überhaupt wie
soll ich denn jetzt hier kohle schmelzen
wenn ich hier hat panik althaus jetzt
noch nicht aber ich muss das portal ist
wenn jetzt voll ist dann können wir ja
erstmal dingsda was beenden wie sie mal
20 minuten
auch stimmt ja dann leute freuen wir
sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder ganz
gut bist dann ca